we have you may have noticed in our
society a group of people who call
themselves progressives you know they've
hijacked the word progress the hidden
assumption is what they want actually is
progress and more powerful government
would be progress I figure if they can
hijack the word progress I can hijack
frequently hi I'm Zack Weiss Muller for
recent TV we're here in Utah in the
overstock.com headquarters with
overstock CEO Patrick Byrne Patrick
thank you very much for talking to us
Zachry it's an honor to be on reason you
recently returned from a medical leave
you had a serious health scare we didn't
even know if you were gonna come back
but now you're back at the helm of
overstock you're launching some new
things do you feel well or even excited
about where things are going from here I
do I feel great I have been I've
actually healthier than I've been in
about 30 years and I've come back just
as we've inflected and we're charging we
have some terrific new products we're
introducing what are some of the new
products that we can look forward to
well some of them have to do with the
our Wall Street endeavors which I'm sure
we'll be talking about t0 yes but also
we're going international in our in our
retail business we're going
international we're adding a cars a
beautiful cars tab where you can search
for million cars that goes live tonight
there's a number of internal things that
that make just make the site smarter
that are rolling out in the weeks ahead
overstock.com is one of the top 25
online retailers and that's why it was
such a big deal when you became the
first of those retailers to start
accepting Bitcoin why did you decide to
do that and what kind of results did you
see well i'm philosophically pro-freedom
and so and i'm a long relationship with
with Nick Gillespie and reasoned and
I've loved this organization so when
Bitcoin came a lie I'm just I'm
supportive of the idea of a form of
money that no government Mandarin can
create with a stroke of a pen
since we're probably not going to get
the country to go to a gold standard or
the
to go to a gold standard and gold would
be impractical and that and you know
because it's not digital Bitcoin seems
like the next best thing maybe even
better because it is because you can
beam it across the galaxy
as this call it in South Park they call
it space cache it's a space cache my
understanding of how you deal with the
space cash is you you pretty much
immediately convert it to US dollars but
you've given your employees the option
to be paid partially or wholly in
Bitcoin has anyone taking you up on that
offer well there are people we convert
when people spend Bitcoin here we
convert 90% of it back into dollars and
we have to pay our suppliers and then we
just were hoarding we're accumulating
10% and we do allow employees to be paid
I think they're bonuses in Bitcoin as a
way of just encouraging adoption we want
to get the you know the they say on Wall
Street liquidity baguettes liquidity and
what is it about Bitcoin and maybe the
blockchain more generally that excites
you the most well the big picture is
this for 6,000 years humans have had
this issue when we engage in consensual
exchange can I trust you or not if
you're a stranger if I'm giving you a
camel I'm trading you for one gold coin
well I don't know if you have to base
the gold coin or not so there's a
business model the business model is
that whoever has monopoly on violence in
this area says okay all issue coins with
money stamped my face on it anyone to
basis this I kill that's just a business
model it's a way of monetizing one's
monopoly on violence we happen to put
that business model we call it
government but fundamentally it's a
business model and there's really a
couple hundred business models that that
have that same common denominator sale
and if you want to buy land for me I can
give you a piece of paper that says I
own this land and now you own it but you
don't know whether to trust that so we
create this central institution the Land
Office Land Registry that we all treat
you don't have to trust me we all have
to trust you we it's just trust it and
so there's all these there's all these
functions that let our civilization run
that really have that common
there's some central institution that
injects trust into a consensual exchange
so that means that for five thousand
years civilization has accumulated these
institutions like barnacles on our hull
and now the blockchain lets us scrape
those barnacles off and one industry
that you were attempting to disrupt with
that model is what we looted to earlier
with t0 which would involve disrupting
the financial industry and trading can
you explain what the concepts behind
that is sure well on Wall Street when
you buy a hundred shares of IBM let's
say on your etrade account and I'm over
on my Ameritrade account and you you're
buying the hundred shares you're paying
let's say nine ninety five I'm paying
nine ninety five to buy them those fees
we pay actually go to feed a lot of
mouths the settlement system the system
that actually lets the stock in money
change hands is much the plumbing in
other words the back-office plumbing of
Wall Street it's much more complicated
and expensive than people understand so
the function is that a big chunk of Wall
Street provides at a very high cost to
society can really now be done more or
less for free through the blockchain so
we have built a blockchain version of
Wall Street and not only are the
expenses much lower but there's all
kinds of you may have heard if you
haven't been living under a rock in the
last decade there's all kinds of
mischief that occurs on Wall Street
various forms of that mischief actually
become impossible in a blockchain based
Wall Street could you give an example of
one type of mischief that might be
prevented by this kind of technology
sure naked short-selling naked
short-selling it's just before
manipulating the market without getting
too technical there's various loopholes
and the rules that govern settlement
there's basically what's fault tolerance
and there's I understand why it was
built with fault tolerance but the fault
tolerance some bad guys figured out how
can you can use that fault tolerance in
the system to actually manipulate by
selling stocks that you don't deliver
and things like this it gets too
technical to explain but it just becomes
impossible to do in a blockchain base
cap
market when we look at Bitcoin for
instance it hasn't always gotten the
warmest reception from politicians and
regulators we have Chuck Schumer for
instance seems highly disturbed by its
existence he's protecting his clients
his clients being the Wall Street firms
do you think that something like this
that applies blockchain technology to
the financial sector would be a major
target for the Chuck Schumer's of the
world it would be and it was but it's
out of their control now this thing can
all be recreated now in any Graduate
Department of Mathematics around the
world it's all based on white papers and
stuff this out there and if they don't
let it go forward in the United States
we got all kinds of countries knocking
on our door in Asia and Europe I think
it's extraordinarily dangerous for the
US if we let other countries take the
lead but if the Chuck Schumer's of the
world try to impede the progress of this
movement they're just going to find it
there circumvented you know they can't
outlaw mathematics they can't this is
all just based on the math and underlies
cryptography they can't be outlawed it
reminds me of the ubers and Airbnb in
the world would people like it's called
like permissionless economy where they
just go ahead and do it and then it's
almost like okay try to regulate this do
you foresee that becoming more and more
common well actually we've taken an
unusual stance because we get how
explosive this is I said from the
beginning I don't want to mount Docs
this I don't want to try to go around
the regulators I'm gonna drive this
right down the middle of Constitution
Avenue or whatever and so we've been
actually working and you're gonna choke
me for saying this we've been working
very constructively with regulators with
FINRA and the SEC I have a website
called deep capture comm which is all
about how captured regulators can be but
and I was worried two years ago that
they were going to really try to stop us
so as to protect the walther Wall Street
clients but that has not been the case
and if anything I don't mean that you
have captured the regulator's no it
means we've liberated that okay actually
we've reached enough of them to undo get
them to see if they're worried about
systemic risk
this is a great solution if they're
worried about the kinds of mischief that
they're supposed to be worried about
this is a great solution it's a crazy
wedge issue because the regulators have
realized that claim I explained a couple
minutes ago is true that the kinds of
mischief they're in the business of
preventing we can actually make
impossible that the key the key point
understand is that the main event of
Bitcoin is really not Bitcoin it's this
thing called the blockchain the
blockchain is the technology that was
invented seven years ago and you can
apply it to money and create things like
Bitcoin but you can apply it to capital
markets and create shares of stock that
have these properties I'll describe
we're also funding a company that is the
blockchain applied to central banking
and it's called bit comm be ITT dot-com
and were the main funders behind it it's
based in Barbados and it's creating
central bank in a box central bank on a
laptop
imagine a central banker can just issue
his fiat currency onto a blockchain
about a month after we announced it the
central banks of Sweden the UK and
Canada all jumped on board and said that
they're starting research projects to do
the same thing a government would be
able to kind of program their central
bank to just inflate the currency at a
steady rate and maybe program it to
meets one or two other goals or
objectives all that becomes possible all
that becomes possible something like
well in our case what we're building is
the mechanism that lets them issue their
fiat on the blockchain
so there would be blockchain versions of
of Canadian dollars or US dollars or or
whatever the next step would be
something like the Taylor rule where
they could actually program an algorithm
that would be that would take all the
guesswork out of it for the markets
where this is exactly what we're going
to issue as the central bank and you
won't automate it of course someday that
may lead to the day that people start
wondering is that candle really worth
the game having this central banker do
that and that that's what we're getting
you do sort of a Bitcoin base so that's
what I was wondering like what would
make people adopt a digital blockchain
based currency versus the fiat currency
and you're outlining there's probably
several steps in between to get there to
mass adoption get to get the getting
them first who would accept a digital
fiat currency is the first step and
listen if the digital fiat system works
better than that'll just persist but if
if the theories of some people are hold
true eventually in this world of
Darwinian selection the the currency
that emerges the digital currency that
emerges won't be fiat you've endorsed
governor Gary Johnson the Libertarian
Party candidate for president what are
you liking about Gary Johnson why did
you endorse them he's Pro freedom I've
known Gary for about ten and I use that
word I we have you may have noticed in
our society a group of people who call
themselves progressives you know they've
hijacked the word progress they've
they're you know they're the hidden
assumption is what they want actually is
progress and more powerful government
would be progress I figure if they can
hijack the word progress I can hijack
the word freedom
try to find our position and the
position of say the viewers of Reason as
pro freedom and Gary tends to be Pro
freedom I've liked Gary since I met him
he has he believes in the right
positions he'd be a great president bill
well would be a great vice president I'm
from New Hampshire and I would lived in
New Hampshire while bill weld was
governor of Massachusetts and he was a
very successful like Gary you have two
successful Republican governors of
democratic states who were both
reelected in landslides bill weld was a
very effective and admired governor in
Massachusetts so the two of them I you
know I think they are head shoulders
waist and knees above the alternatives
you have been funding a movie called
rigs 2016 which is about the campaign of
Gary Johnson and William weld and also I
think about the two-party system could
you tell us about that project and why
you decided to get involved I actually
funded two years ago a fellow I don't
know who makes documentaries and then he
crowdfunded some more to make a movie
about our two-party system not even
knowing who the candidates were make a
documentary about the two-party system
the role of
Media plays and then we met somebody
from the from that note that has been
traveling with Carrie Johnson guy named
James Greenwood it's been traveling with
Gary Johnson for a year he's not part of
the campaign but he's been filming the
campaign and we realized that so he had
all this great film and document and
documenting the campaign and we for two
years have been documenting documenting
other aspects of the political system
and we realized we could get together
and create a love child and the love
child is this movie rigged the Citizens
United case was about a political
documentary an anti Hillary Clinton
documentary since you're now making a
political documentary in an election
year are you afraid of Hillary Clinton
coming after you well I would expect
that if either Hillary Clinton or Donald
Trump get elected neither of them are
going to be too happy about what they
see in the documentary the only one who
I think has a history of being
vindictive and retaliatory would be
Hillary Clinton and for our next
interviews me in an orange jumpsuit
somewhere I won't be surprised the
documentary is called rigs as we tape
this Gary Johnson has been excluded from
the at least the first presidential
debate because he didn't meet a 15%
polling threshold set by the Commission
on Presidential Debates
is that a symptom of a rigged system and
do you think Gary Johnson is gonna be
able to overcome it's absolutely a
symbol or a sign of a rigged system what
they're really afraid of if he gets on
the stage I think the race is over both
because of the antipathy the American
people feel towards the two current
candidates plus as the name of your
magazine and show acknowledges that
pro-freedom people there's our based and
reason and when a guy who's based in
reason and logic like Gary Johnson gets
up and talks to the machan studebaker
magog's I think he would wipe the floor
with him we've talked about Gary Johnson
we've talked a little bit about Hillary
Clinton when we talk about Donald Trump
he's someone that you have called a
disgrace to America what is disgraceful
about Donald Trump the way he conducts
himself
I don't consider Donald Trump a
businessman Donald Trump inherited
million dollars we rented all the way up
to zero went bankrupt four times
conducted himself extremely improperly
as a businessman the way he shafted
various bondholders and played games and
such then he reinvented himself as a
reality TV star and made tens of
millions of dollars more power to him
this is America and good for him
but you know Kim Kardashian made tens of
millions of dollars as a reality TV star
I don't want her to be president and
Donald Trump has no business being
president he's a fake
a capitalist he's a fake businessman he
just plays one on this day on a TV show
no one in the right mine
20 years ago no one would know one
invested with Donald Trump anymore you
wouldn't invest with Donald Trump
because of the way he's treated his
investors and and such so so we're
sending all that aside then from the way
he started you know his campaign talked
about the Mexican rapist and I actually
went on Fox once he did that and said
mad unkind things about him but then
when he said this stuff about John
McCain you know he's a loser I want a
guy you know however you feel about the
Vietnam War saying that about John
McCain I want a guy who doesn't get shot
down or whatever Todd that's just not
the kind of guy we want this president
I'm Hillary of course belongs in an
orange jumpsuit i am i think it's it's
you know just the fact that she's
running marks our descent into banana
republic status a little if she wins
surveying the political social and
cultural landscape right now as a CEO
and entrepreneur are you optimistic
about the future or are you pessimistic
well I'm optimistic about the like for
as a CEO for our company and such now
I'm quite pessimistic about where the
country is I think that we are you know
nothing's been fixed in the system I
think we're on the very brink of a
another financial crisis worse
quite possibly worse than 2008 all
they're doing is they're giving
novocaine
they're shooting novocaine with cheap
free money in the system to float us to
try to get us through this election
they're never going to raise they can't
raise interest rates because once they
do it will reveal there is no recovery
there's no recovery it's all fake and
we're gonna be in a recession as soon as
they try to raise interest rates if
we're really not already so now I think
that there's a huge financial global
financial crisis probably gonna break
first in Europe and then ripple its way
here expect something really really ugly
here but on the other hand we're we're
mostly in the elektron business I
wouldn't want to be in a business with
in a department store big mall and
you've got all that capital tied up but
in our business you know if the if the
cookie crumbles it crumbles from the
outside in and we're standing in the
middle Patrick Byrne thank you very much
for talking to us Thank You Zachary for
a reason TV I'm Zach Weissmuller